in the Border City of Brownsville a
vigil was held last night for eight
people killed when an SUV plowed into a
group waiting near a Migrant Center many
of whom are believed to be Asylum
Seekers 10 people were injured police
are now investigating whether it was
intentional Nicole scan goes in
Brownsville outside of the Migrant
Center with more on this Nicole good
morning
Anne-Marie good morning and another
tragedy this time in the Border
Community here in Brownsville Texas we
spoke to the manager of this nearby
shelter that had been housing migrants
she told us that most of the victims who
were killed were Venezuelan men and they
were in route to their future homes
after long and often difficult Journeys
into the United States they were just a
bus and a plane ticket away from their
lives here in America
a bus stop turned into a gruesome scene
when a vehicle slammed into a crowd of
people we're pausing the video because
it's too graphic and disturbing to fully
show horrific it was terrible people
were running to help them the bodies
were all over the place the victims were
lined up along the road outside the
osnan homeless shelter when the SUV
struck them around 8 30 a.m Witnesses
say the driver then tried to flee but
was detained by others at the scene
there's reports that are going out that
he was driving reckless leaders others
saying that he was intoxicated and
there's others saying that he was
intentional seven people died at the
scene one died at a nearby hospital and
several others remain in critical
condition among the dead Angel vay
cavarka his cousin says he came across
the body seconds after the crash
authorities say those victims include
Asylum Seekers from Latin America the
Border community of Brownsville Texas is
in shock it's also been dealing with a
major increase in the number of migrants
Crossing into the city in the last week
of April border patrol says 15
000 crossed into Brownsville compared
with 1700 in the first two weeks of
April Mirna artiaga manages the osnum
shelter we have a lot of people from the
community coming to help us counsel
these people because they stay they're
traumatized
the driver who has not been identified
other than being a Hispanic male is in
custody at an area Hospital police say
he's not cooperating but they've ordered
a toxicology report to determine if he
was under the influence Anne-Marie so
Nicole let me ask you you know we're
talking about you know migrants I wonder
if that presents a challenge in terms of
identifying these victims or getting in
touch with next of Ken
yeah Anne-Marie there is a long road
ahead for identifying these victims and
this is where Federal authorities come
in U.S border and Customs here on the
scene yesterday and they will be working
alongside the Brownsville police
alongside the FBI as this investigation
unfolds they will be determining the
nationalities of some of these victims
their names reaching out to family
members we are aware of at least some
family members who have learned of the
loss of their loved ones at a vigil held
across the street at that migrant
shelter that we talked about that
shelter that was housing migrants we met
the cousin of Angel vay cavarkas who
told us that he bore witness to the
horrific crash just seconds after that
crash coming to collect his backpack
Reeve his cousin's life and so we are
learning the names we are getting an
update from law enforcement later today
but it would not surprise me if we did
not learn every single name at that time
you know police continuing to work with
CBP on this yeah this is tough and so in
regards to the suspect I know that you
know it's we sort of don't know a lot at
this point but you know is there
anything more about what people witness
or or anything that authorities have
told us about the suspect
yeah very few details regarding the
suspect in part because police tell us
he's not cooperating he is in custody
he's recovering at the hospital but he
has not been Cooperative of course we
know the FBI is also uh here with the
Brownsville police and they're going to
continue to try to get as many details
as they can you heard about that
toxicology report that's been ordered to
determine if the suspect had alcohol in
his system he was charged with reckless
driving yesterday but police do
anticipate more charges there they are
looking into whether or not this is
intentional and Witnesses on the scene
tell us that he after the crash got out
of his vehicle he tried to flee the
scene he was yelling obscenities at the
victims before individuals here were
able to surround him in sort of detain
him here memory wow and you mentioned
the vigil that you had gone to last
night you know as you point out this is
a community that's been dealing with an
influx in migrants I I wonder about the
resources I mean do they have the
resources not only to deal with this
influx but now this additional tragedy
yeah I and so U.S border and Customs uh
have been down here for weeks gearing up
for the lifting of title 42 which is
expected to bring an uptick in migrant
uh arrivals here in Brownsville Texas
certainly Brownsville Police Department
also assisting law enforcement so this
is one more thing you know for them to
investigate I did ask police just that
question yesterday if they felt they
were resourced enough they said look
this is our jobs we do it every single
day you know we are here you know in
terms of the you know border crisis more
broadly speaking we do know that there
are troops headed to El Paso and then
there will be more border agents sent
from West Texas right here in South
Texas uh you know to handle what is
expected to be as many as 10 000
migrants crossing the border every day
Anne-Marie as for that vigil that you
mentioned the community has just
absolutely risen to the occasion we saw
a handful of Faith leaders come together
to hold yesterday's mass and it should
be noted that at the scene itself
Witnesses say part of the reason the
driver did not get away is that so many
that sprang into action coming across
the street from the shelter to make sure
that that individual was detained and uh
that police could get to the scene in
time wow Nicole snaga thank you very
much
thank you